scènes de liesse à bengazi les partisans
du général haftar laissent exploser leur
joie après son allocution qui s'inscrit
dans l'histoire du pays nous sommes
fiers du mandat du peuple pour cette
mission historique dans ces
circonstances exceptionnelles et nous
annonçons la fin de l'accord politique
fait suite à une décision du peuple
libyen la source de tous les pouvoirs
nous acceptons la volonté du peuple et
son mandat un soulagement pour la
plupart des libyens
malgré le confinement ils ont tenu à
célébrer cette annonce et exprimer leur
soutien indéfectible à leur leader le
peuple demande le soutien en force
militaire arabe libyenne dirigé par le
maréchal khalifa ben belkacem haftar la
demande du pape est bien connu oui aux
dirigeants oui au maréchal oui au sang
des martyrs
oui aux blessés oui à la libye de rass
ajdir à mme saad
dans sa déclaration le maréchal haftar
qui contrôlent l'est et une partie du
sud du pays indiqué mettre un terme aux
accords de skhirat portant sur les
conditions de paix dans le pays ait des
propos qui ont beaucoup fait réagir le
pouvoir à tripoli
le gouvernement d'union nationale a
dénoncé un nouveau coup d'état en
reprochant au maréchal haftar de vouloir
mettre en place une dictature
dix ans après celle de mouammar kadhafi
c'est une farce et un nouveau coup
d'état qui s'ajoute à une longue série
le maréchal a star veut dissimuler la
défaite de ses milices et mercenaires et
l'échec de son projet dictatorial la
communauté internationale a également
réagi aux propos de l'homme fort de
l'est libyen notamment la russie par le
biais de son ministre des affaires
étrangères sergueï lavrov qui a indiqué
ne pas approuver cette déclaration et
auquel les états unis et l'union
européenne ont emboîté le pas alors que
le monde s'évertue à combattre le court
aux navires us la libye de son côté
demeure plongée dans
un conflit qui ne cesse de s'aggraver
pandémie ou pas